si tu veux savoir c'est que certains
profs ils seront pas tous là l'année
prochaine donc on a Adeline et Yanis
Marshall qui eux vont être conduits par
contre
le pire de brouer et leur balance elle
ouais
elle ne sera pas elle ne seront certes
ils seront certainement pas là l'année
prochaine mais moi leur ballon moi
j'aime bien
ça sert à rien déjà dans les précédentes
ça sert à rien enfin
je peux ne pas être d'accord avec vous
franchement c'est l'un des seuls cours
qui m'a aidé dans ce dans cette dans
cette
montée sur scène vas-y tu es où au
supermarché
surtout avoir confiance en moi faut
savoir improviser quoi c'est pour ça que
je te dis ça c'est que c'est pas c'est
pas rien c'est des conneries c'est sûr
mais c'est pas rien à faire et confiance
Julien